we have a president now who is a fake
catholic his name
is joe biden but the washington post
doesn't want to admit that so joe biden
is in hot water right now because joe
biden is in
in outright obstinance against
the church's teaching on the issue of
abortion and the issue of abortion
is not like other issues saint pope john
paul ii
pointed this out it's not just one issue
among many the right to life is a
prerequisite for all of the other rights
one may not disagree like pope benedict
for instance said that catholics may
have a legitimate disagreement about the
death penalty pope john paul ii said the
same thing
doctors of the church have explicitly
defended the death penalty
blessed pope pius ix carried out many
death penalties and
so catholics can disagree on that as a
prudential matter
catholics cannot disagree on abortion
and joe biden does and he celebrates
abortion he expands the killing of
innocent little babies in this country
so the bishops finally i'm so pleased to
say this the bishops are standing up and
saying
we're going to have to deal with joe
biden here and here's how it was
presented in the washington post
a rising group of right-wing u.s
catholic bishops
is colliding with a very catholic
president who supports
abortion rights right-wing
group of bishops colliding
with a very catholic
president everything about this is
untrue everything about this is a lie a
very big lie actually
it is not right-wing bishops who are
doing this it is
bishops who believe in the catholic
faith who believe in the teaching of the
church it is just bishop you just say
bishops and they're not colliding on
this issue of morals and faith
it's not it's not like well you got the
president on one hand and you got the
bishops on the other
that's not how the catholic church works
the bishops
are bringing the president who is a
member of their flock into line
they're not on equal footing here the
bishops are
reprimanding or showing that they may
reprimand
the president and the very catholic he's
not particularly catholic
at all he goes to mass he apparently
receives communion which is eating his
own
damnation to use the scriptural line
and and the teaching of the church and
the bishops in an act of compassion
are suggesting telling him to not
receive the eucharist until he
stops living in the state of scandal and
sin
and changes his views and goes to
confession
an exact flip here but we are told he's
a very catholic president because it is
on the one hand we're told it's very bad
to be catholic right
dianne feinstein yells at amy coney
barrett because the dogma lives loudly
within her the catholic dogma
we're told it's very bad to be catholic
but then joe biden is very catholic but
the reason that the
left says that joe biden's very catholic
in this admiring way
is because they know joe biden's not
very catholic that his real
religion is progressivism
hey don't go anywhere because youtube
will tell you
sometimes that you know you'll get
notifications for my show well you know
what i call that i call that a big lie
you need to make sure that you ring the
bell that you like that you subscribe
and then you will have a slightly better
chance of getting notifications when we
get new videos out see you then